two
and two on hunter renfrow
swing a high flab on the line driven
deep garcia turning
and it is gone into the second deck here
on a red throw with a massive shot and
the red sox lead it two to nothing
oh my goodness did he ever get that
watch the location of this curveball
it does nothing but spin to the inside
part of the plate
if you're a right-handed hitter those
are pitches you dream about
second tank
this one right back up the middle
culverson
with a base hit to start things in the
third
1-1 to kenner falefa and that one is
right into right field for a base hit
culverson
heading to third base and he'll get in
there
just like the first inning the rangers
with a couple of one out
singles the dog back holding a run
around at first base
[Music]
it looked like connor's it looked like
kyner is trying to shoot the ball into
right field take advantage of that hole
and he did he got it just by dahl back
into right field
3-2 this will hit well into left field
base hit
culverson will touch the plate rbi
single
for nick sola and it's a 2-1 ball game
that's a change-up and that's a rope
hit it by the shortstop in the left
field he's weighted on it
3-1 and that's ball four so the bases
will be loaded
seven-game hitting streak going for name
that's a base hit one run is in the
rangers will take the lead
solace scores a two-run single for nate
lowe
and it's three to two it's all about
taking advantage of your opportunities
and that's taking advantage of an
opportunity that's a slider that's
supposed to be down and away it just
spins belt high
middle of the plate and nate took
advantage of his opportunity
continues to pound the ball with men in
scoring position
huge hit rangers down by one bases
loaded
rodriguez makes a mistake and nate made
him pay for it
raphael leading the major leagues in
barrels
i like that going the other way down to
the corner garcia trying to dig it out
heading into second base and pulling up
with the double as rafael devers
hits it usually on the barrel and that's
the impressive thing about devin's you
know he gets a breaking ball he gets a
curveball right here and it stays
outside he doesn't try to pull it
he'll just hit it hard to the opposite
field in front of christian vasquez was
singled
and stole a base and scored a run
right good job rafael moving up to third
so first two red sox connect
a little roller here to short kind of
palette will go to first
and the run comes in and the socks have
quickly tied the game
bobby will pick up an rbi there
and down the second moves vasquez
all right hitting a basic so arroyo is
on to begin the fifth inning for the sox
another hanging breaking ball that time
from lyles
runner's gonna go and that is up high
and he walked him
so ball four runners on at first and
second
j.d trying to time him and
a 3-2 again
that's going to drop into right field
down for a base hit here comes a royal
rounding
gallow fire not a good throw he's in the
score
that's skipped and the sox take the lead
4-3
rbi number 26 for jd martinez
that's to the opposite field it's not
exactly crushed
the ball hitting on him a little bit but
a good read also at second base by
arroyo he knew that ball was not going
to be caught
and that's why he's safe at home plate
so the red sox play a little first and
third
as that ball cannot be cut off it kind
of rolled in the hole plate
and you'll hit that one for a single
into left field that'll bring in another
one verdu go home
yeah i didn't understand that defense i
really didn't i
you know if he's back a couple of steps
he probably backhands that ball and
maybe turns it into a double play
but playing where he was playing it was
a change up
and he had no chance at all
[Applause]
he reaches down and gets one to third
base this one throws
a point rather in time and trevino
kept his foot apparently on the plate
for the force out
but then when you see the replay you'll
see his foot is
on the base when he catches it and then
comes off
dragged it dragged it right away to the
naked eye when you watch it happen you
say whoa he's off the base
[Applause]
and he strikes him out dulbeck goes down
swinging two away in the inning
fastball got him swinging and the inning
is done back-to-back strikeouts
by taylor hearn
strike things here against connor
philipe
[Applause]
and he makes it a one-run game
you know i think when the average fan
thinks of isaiah they think of a gold
glove winner
lead-off hitter a guy that can hit the
ball to all fields
but he might surprise people in the
power department
and i don't think you can hit a ball 423
feet to dead center field
and not be a guy that you look at with a
potential to hit 20 home runs in a
season
watching him in batting practice
swinging the ball swinging the back
great batting practice
and he hammers the ball down the right
field line if it stays fair
willie came into the game with a
seven-game hitting streak
and one of the things that he's talked
about
that his buddy verdugo does is hit the
ball to all fields and in this game
he's got a solid hit to left field that
was a pitch he could pull that pitcher's
inside part of the plate he hit 20 home
runs a couple of years ago by pulling
the ball out of the ballpark but
it had the break of a slider field and
that one could be trouble
take a look at it he lines it past the
second baseman and the right fielder
can't catch it he actually got to it
his glove comes down on the other side
of the ball he just didn't catch it
but because he was on the dead run and
never touched it it's going to go as a
triple
he's at third and a fly ball could get
him in
that should get it done gallow lines it
up
zander coming he will score
so it pays off on the sacrifice by
christian vasquez
red sox down now 7-6
two one and this ball lined out to the
gap left center field
that'll definitely get a run home
culverson the second he'll pull up their
back-to-back doubles
in the eighth inning
well the rangers just keep swinging the
bats they've hit a lot of balls hard in
this game
singles doubles you name it
pounding red sock pitching
35 129 in the house tonight and they're
all
on their feet
the one two got him looking
and kennedy locks the door in the ninth
inning
on an 8-6 win for the rangers and
they've taken two of three to start this
series